حسنًا، خلال مؤتمر صحفي، أوضح
وزير الدفاع الأمريكي لويد أوستن
أن الهجوم المميت بطائرة بدون طيار على
القوات الأمريكية في الأردن خلال
عطلة نهاية الأسبوع قد تجاوز الحدود بشكل أساسي.
هنا،
كان هذا الهجوم بالتحديد
فظيعًا وأنك تعلم أن
الهجوم كان على  منطقة النوم في
إحدى قواعدنا، حان الوقت
للتخلص من قدرة أكبر مما
أخذناه في
الماضي، وهذا يبدو هدفًا مفتوحًا جدًا،
لذا أه لتحقيق مدى
انتشاره على مدى عدد الأيام أو الأسابيع
هل تتوقع أن يكون الرد وما
هو تعريف النجاح
هنا نعم إنه سؤال جيد جون
ولست متأكدًا من أنني اعتقدت أنه مهما كان
مسار العمل الذي قررته أه
قيادة
الإدارة فسيكون أه  أكثر
من مجرد ضربة بسيطة
حدثت في الماضي، فقد حدثت مع
قوات التحالف، لذلك أعتقد أن هذه الضربة التالية
بناءً على البث الذي
قام به الوزير أوستن ستستمر على الأرجح
لأيام إن لم يكن لأسابيع، وستضرب
أهدافًا متعددة وكما أفهمها.
سنسعى لملاحقة
الاهتمام الإيراني ووكلاء أورانوس الآن
هذا ما هاجموه في الماضي
أه لكنه يخبرني أنه من المحتمل أن
يكون هناك أكثر من مجرد
نشاط حركي ناقشناه في تلك
الليلة عندما كنت مع  لك أنه
يمكن أن يكون أكثر مما ترى ضرب أه
بأنظمة الأسلحة وفي الحقيقة يمكن أن
يكون هناك الكثير مما يحدث في
المجال الدبلوماسي والاقتصادي والمعلوماتي
وهناك دلائل تشير إلى أن مجرد
الحديث عن رد فعل معزز منا قد كان له
تأثير على الجماعات المسلحة التي تقف وراء
غارة الطائرات بدون طيار في نهاية الأسبوع والتي أعلنت
يوم الثلاثاء تعليق المزيد من الهجمات
على القوات الأمريكية في المنطقة. هناك أيضًا
معلومات استخباراتية يقول مسؤولون أمريكيون إنها
تشير إلى أن القيادة الإيرانية متوترة
بشأن بعض تصرفات الجماعات الوكيلة لها
في العراق وسوريا واليمن.  أم، وعلى
وجه الخصوص، مقاتلو هاي في اليمن الذين
يطلقون النار الآن بشكل عشوائي على السفن
التي يبدو أنها في البحر الأحمر، لديهم بعض
الشكاوى من أحد
أهم حلفاء تان، وهي الصين، لذا
خذ كل هذا معًا هل يلعب دورًا
في ما يفعله الجيش الأمريكي  الرد
سيكون ذلك الرد العسكري الذي يمكن أن
يحدث في أي لحظة الآن، نعم يجب أن يحدث،
وهذا ما كنت أقصده عندما
تحدثت عن الرد الدبلوماسي، كل
هذه الاعتبارات جزء مما
يسمونه لجنة الانتخابات التمهيدية عندما يقوم
المسؤولون الأساسيون في  إدارة
لقاء حول الجوانب المختلفة
لهذه المعركة، ما هي الميزة بالنسبة للولايات
المتحدة وما الذي يجب عليهم
توخي الحذر منه فيما يتعلق بالتحالفات أه كما تعلم
أنك رأيت الإيرانيين يبدو أنهم
ينسحبون قليلاً بناءً على بعض
المدخلات  من العراق وأعتقد أن ذلك كان
مدفوعًا بالجهود الدبلوماسية بين
الولايات المتحدة والعراق أه قائلاً لقد
سمحت لهذه
القوات الخاصة بقوات التعبئة هذه داخل
بلدك وهي الآن خارجة عن السيطرة
ويجب عليك إخراجهم منها  السيطرة
وأعتقد أن الحكومة العراقية نقلت هذه
الرسالة إلى الحكومة الإيرانية وعليك
أن تتذكر أن الحكومة العراقية
هي حكومة شيعية أه رئيس
وزرائهم شيعي لذا فهم يتحدثون
مع دولهم الحدودية الإيرانية حول
ما يجب عليهم فعله  وما يحتاجون
إلى تجنبه فيما يتعلق بمواصلة القتال
ضد داعش، هذا الشيء
معقد للغاية. جون كما تعلم،
السيناتور الجمهوري ليندسي جراهام يتحدث
بقوة أكبر عندما يتعلق الأمر
بالمخاطرة بحرب مع إيران، فها هو
إذا كنت تريد حربًا  معنا،
سنزيلك من الخريطة المنزعجة. أنا
لست قلقًا بشأن خسارة الحرب مع إيران،
يجب أن يكونوا قلقين بشأن خسارة
الحرب في اليوم السابق.
قال رئيس الحرس الثوري الإيراني إن إيران ليست في
سعي للحرب ولكن  اقتباس نحن لسنا
خائفين من الحرب لن ندع أي تهديد
يمر دون إجابة أه لذلك فقط للتذكير كما
تعلمون الأصول العسكرية الإيرانية
لم تكن على الأراضي العراقية قبل 20 عاما
سبب وجودها الآن هو بسبب الغزو
الأمريكي للعراق لذلك حتى  فأنت
تعلم أن العراق كان بمثابة ثقل موازن إقليمي
لإيران، كما تعلم أن الأمر معقد، لذا فإن
وجهة نظري هنا هي أنه على الرغم من أن الحروب لها الكثير
من العواقب السيئة غير المقصودة حقًا،
ولهذا السبب تريد تجنبها في
المقام الأول، فمن الصواب أن يفعلوا ذلك، وهذا
إنه أمر محير تمامًا بالنسبة
لي أن يقول مشرع أمريكي أه السيناتور
جراهام شيئًا بهذا
القدر من التبجح وهذا القدر من التبجح
لأنه ليس من يخوض
الحرب وليس أيضًا من يتحمل
المسؤولية عنها بل هو شخص واحد
وهذا رئيس
الولايات المتحدة، لذلك عندما يكون لديك هؤلاء
الأفراد الذين لديهم هذا النوع من
التهديد والتهديد فيما يتعلق بالعلاقات الخارجية،
على الرغم من أن السيناتور جراهام لديه
الكثير من الخبرة مع الدول الأخرى، فقد
خدم بالزي الرسمي كمحامي للقوات الجوية
لكنه ليس الشخص الذي يعمل في
الخط الأمامي وهو ليس الشخص الذي يتعين عليه إجراء
هذا النوع من المكالمات التي
يتعين على القائد الأعلى أن يجريها، لذلك أجد فقط أن
هذا النوع من التعليق
غير ملائم للولايات المتحدة
وما نحاول القيام به  القيام بردع الأعمال
في الشرق الأوسط وعدم الدخول في حرب
هي نقطة جيدة جدًا في النهاية سيدي أه
الجنرال هودلي كما هو الحال دائمًا، شكرًا لك سيدي،
نحن نقدر رؤيتك، شكرًا لك
جون